foreign
producer James sent us this article that
has to do with work and I wanted your
hot take on this Ken here's the headline
here's the headline should I take a
lunch break at work one in four gen Z
employees worry leaving their desks to
eat is a bad look to the higher-ups
here's why that's nonsense so it goes on
to explain probably hopefully close to
our take let me answer the question
yes you should take a lunch break
um if you are in a place
where you taking a lunch break is
actually frowned upon I don't mean like
in your head and this data's saying that
a lot of gen Z workers are worried that
it looks bad well there's a difference
between I'm worried I'm manifesting this
thought that's not true and it actually
being true so if George you were working
in a place where your leader is frowning
upon it making passive aggressive
comments about you taking a lunch hour
you shouldn't be there much longer find
you another place uh and here's why
the data Bears out that you're not
actually more productive you may think
you're getting more done but it's going
to end up being a negative for you by
not getting up from your desk and a lot
of these kids I look to the art a lot of
these young people are eating at their
desk they're called desktop diners
desktop diners it's a fun little
necklace we got a name for everything
first it was quiet quitting now we got
desktop diners
um
I I think it's good for your mental
health it's good for your uh physical
health uh to get up change locations you
know there's all kinds of data about uh
walking for 10 to 15 minutes before you
have a big meeting
I've talked about that on the Ken
Coleman show you know it's a it's a
creative release
uh it allows you to kind of get some
perspective and uh so anyway the lunch
break is the same idea I you know I got
I have several friends here in the
building that they go work out during
lunch uh Damon Goud my Fearless brain
leader works out during lunch and it
shows it shows
um and you know in multiple ways so you
know I do think that there's something
to that and I'm calling myself out on
this because sometimes I go without
lunch
that has a cool name too Ken it's called
fasting now I'm intermittent fasting
that's what I sell it's real trendy what
it really is is that uh I have poor
planning and uh you know I don't have
time uh but I need to make time but now
for me I keep my energy up during that
time but for someone every day to be
sitting there feeling like I can't leave
my desk or else someone's gonna fire me
or they're gonna think poorly with me
I'm telling you something young people
you have you've got to get some facts to
support that and if you don't have any
facts you need to get over that uh and
just be responsible
be responsible well and that with a
report that this study talks about found
that stopping to eat and taking mental
breaks can prevent burnout especially in
the context of the extra stressful times
workers have faced over the past few
years and so if you think you're being
more productive you're actually being
less productive and you're on your way
to burnout if you can't take that break
that's right your your mind needs a a
break you know your body needs the break
it's get up you know uh by the way if
I'm a young professional
if I'm going to eat out every day and
some of you need to not be eating out
you need to pack your lunch and go to a
local park but you know what I'm trying
to do I'm making phone calls to people I
want to connect with I'm eating lunch
with people I want to connect with I'm
using that time to grow professionally
but I'm away from my desk absolutely and
it's actually discouraged here at Ramsey
if we see a team member eating at their
desk we're going hey what's going on
here you go we have got a whole
cafeteria where we can connect with team
members and occasionally you'll have a
lunch meeting or something like that by
the way no one else wants to smell your
tuna fish sandwich for the rest
can we can we just let's be real
practical for a moment especially in the
microwave you got to avoid microwave
fish in 2020. you want to win
professionally don't bring fish to the
office cafeteria not the advice we
thought we'd hear on the show but it's
the it's the advice we got sometimes it
just presents itself